^- Hi, my name is Briana.
^I just moved to Downtown Houston
^and we're going to show you our apartment.
^- Hey, my name is Dilip.
^I live on the Upper East Side in this pretty dope spot.
^I pay about $1,500 in rent
^which is a steal for the place you're going to see
^so come on in.
The cool thing about our building
is our landlord put in some electronic locks recently
that work with Bluetooth and it works great
when I have my phone on me
but there's been a couple of times
when I've had 1% battery and rushing home at 4.00 a.m.
Right as you enter the apartment
that is the kitchen that I share
with the three other college friends
that I live with in this apartment.
We all try to cook a little bit
and split up time of who gets to cook when.
What's really crazy for New York
is we have this dishwasher right here,
you don't see that a lot.
This is like a thing to show off
when we have friends over and it's like,
"Hell yeah, we got a dishwasher in New York."
I think this is a little excessive.
We've got a wine cooler.
We don't even drink a lot of wine
so I don't know what we use this for
but it just looks really dope so it's pretty nice.
- This is our apartment.
We've got bar stools.
The kitchen area, stove, sink,
^garbage disposal
and here is our laundry room.
- Alright, welcome to my bedroom.
I guess you could say this is where the magic happens.
It's not too big, it's pretty cozy.
You're not going to find a lot of big bedrooms in New York
so I'm lucky with what I have here.
I really wish I had space for a desk or something
but I kind of like make do with this bookshelf,
it's like a standing desk.
If you can't tell already from the guitar on the wall
and all the other stuff,
I'm really into music
so this also doubles as my home studio sometimes.
I just kind of like put my mike in the closet
to kind of sound proof
and from my laptop here I record music too sometimes.
I also have nice access to the fire escape outside.
It's been a dream of mine to serenade a lady out there.
Still hasn't happened,
looking for the right one but maybe someday.
One of my favorite things in the room
is the wall album art I have up here.
All my favorite albums here, every day I wake up,
it's the first thing I see
and I can just throw on one of those albums in the morning
as I'm getting ready for work.
Make do with what I got.
- Here's the bedroom.
So a nice view of the city and the freeway,
got the TV over here.
This is our bathroom.
His and hers sinks, nice wide mirror,
nice brown rugs with the black shower curtain.
Spacious bathtub.
- Warning, the bathroom's kind of small,
not what you expect in like most places,
especially somewhere like mid West or South.
In New York it's really small.
This is what you get, you know.
Everything's kind of cramped together.
It's also not just mine, I share it with one other person.
Constantly competing for shower time in the morning.
We're trying to make it work and it's not too bad.
The living room right here.
We all kind of hang out here,
eat together when possible
or just kind of like get some work done.
We have that exposed brick right here,
definitely a staple of any hipster vibe
in any New York apartment.
There's an extra bedroom in this apartment
that we kind of converted into a living room.
We've got our couch here, got our TV,
got some good video games.
This is like where we all hang out when we have people over.
We're supposed to fit comfortably on this couch
like five or six people,
but we've had like 15, 20 people in here before.
We squeezed in, we made it work.
- That's a reclining chair, nice comfortable couch,
glass table, TV with the PS cords and video games.
- One of the surprising things about this apartment
that you don't find in New York that often
is we got a backyard.
In the summer we've had some parties before,
sometimes projected movies on that wall.
- Out here we've got the balcony
with a lovely view of a vacant lot and city all around,
a nice freeway to the left.
- One weird thing about our apartment
is we have this like giant beautiful window
here in our dining room.
It stares right at the brick wall until you notice sunlight,
so it's typical of New York.
- Then we come here, it's the fitness room.
That's a treadmill,
that's the free weights going on, get some muscle action,
a little bicycle
but it makes it look like you're bicycling somewhere
so you don't get bored while you're exercising.
Motivates you to put in those miles.
Right here is the yoga studio / rehearsal space.
No one's in here!
- Going into here you can see this small area right here,
so go in here, this is our gym,
this is all we have, we have a pull up bar.
Take it down for some push ups, do some pull ups.
We don't really have a gym in this apartment building
so this is what we got.
Cheapest gym membership.
- This is our pool area, bam!
- We actually have two floors to this apartment.
Two of our bedrooms are upstairs,
other two guys live downstairs.
This is where it gets really special.
Again, in New York, you don't see this all the time.
We have our own laundry and dryer.
This is what we show people when people visit us,
when people come over, this is how we impress them.
So lucky to have this apartment in New York for $1,500,
it's super rare to get.
It has a washer dryer, a dishwasher,
and although it's not a lot of space,
like four guys and we have a lot of people over frequently,
we make it work and we have a pretty good time.
So thanks again for checking it out
and hope to see you in New York.
- Thanks for checking out our apartment.
If you live in Houston you can get great amenities,
tons of space and live stress free.
- [Both] Bye!